[Musique]
quel bonheur de vous retrouver donc pour
au bonheur des livres c'est le cas de le
dire avec Jean-Marie Perrier maises nuit
blanches publié aux éditions Kalman Levi
au milieu vous avez mes insupportables
notes que voici et nous sommes avec
Danne Franck aussi qui publie un livre
tout à fait étonnant qui s'appelle
l'arrestation là les notes sont encore
pire qui est publié aux éditions grass
euh j'espère que vous allez faire
connaissance j'espère que vous allez
être heureux et Dan je vous offre ce
petit chef-dœuvre de Jean-Marie Perrier
alors vous savez que Jean-Marie dan je
vais commencer à lireaintenant attendez
attendez Jean-Marie vous savez qu'on le
caricature comme le photographe de SLC
l'homme qui a fait les photos de toutes
les stars de la planète dans les années
60 c'est vrai mais sa vie ça a été bien
autre chose il a fait de la publicité il
a fait du du cinéma et je voudrais vous
expliquer la raison pour laquelle nous
avons réuni car c'est le concept de
bonur des livres d'ne Franck et et et et
Jean-Marie Perrier a priori quand vous
voyez Jean-Marie vous dites c'est le
bonheur la Jet 7 les années 60 et cetera
et cetera mais en même temps il faut le
dire aujourd'hui c'est devenu la
mythologie mondiale il suffit de voir
l'impact à le dernier disque des Rolling
Stones même s'il n'est pas fantastique
dan on a l'impression que c'est
quelqu'un d'à peu près la même
génération qui publie la restrestation
chez gr je me dis c'est amusant de les
confonder parce que Dan n'écoutait que
de la musique classique et il a fait de
la tôle pardonnez-moi l'expression pour
avoir abrité sans le savoir des gens en
action directe donc deux personnes
pratiquement de la même génération en
tout cas pour les jeunes qui ont deux
destins différents je raconte un mot de
Dan parce que c'est quand même
incroyable c'est le fait que vous soyez
évidemment tombé sur dénonciation la
dénonciation c'est la voici hein c'est
pas 60 la flingueuse de l'avenue truden
et Frédéric pseudo blond Blon juif cor
terroriste d'Adé d'Action Directe unité
Marcel Rayman et occasionnellement du
FLNC elle avait un Beretta 765 détails
non parus dans la presse elle a habité
chez Dan Fran bang balancé l'écrivain
qu'elle connaissait déjà au lycée de rel
et chez la maîtresse de Danne Franck qui
habite 19 ru du temple et cetera et
cetera je rappelle que vous avez écrit
depuis l'âge c'est votre métier depuis
l'âge de 20 ans vous avez publié une
quinzaine de romans vous avez oui plus
plus avec vos train plus les livres que
vous avez écrit avec enk Bilal donc ce
sont ces deux mondes que nous allons
confronter premier monde le
vôtre
Jean-Marie le texte que vous avez écrit
sur sa gant car il y a des photos mais
ce n'est pas le Jean-Marie perriier
photographe qui est là je le trouve
sublime nous y sommes et puis un jour
c'est pratiquement vous aujourd'hui et
puis un jour on se regarde dans la glace
vous êtes avec Sagan imaginaire et voilà
qu'on est vieux et c'est alors qu'on se
retrouve dans un appartement en face de
François Sagan et qu'on ne sait pas quoi
dire on aimerait être plus cultivé avoir
tout lu alors on sautit et puis on
comprend qu'on a vécu dans le même
siècle en se croisant sans se connaître
vraiment et qu'elle aussi a un parcours
et qu'elle se demande peut-être ce
qu'elle fait là àive devant cet ancien
ami photographe qui est venu au monde
sans le vouloir la dame a des silences
qui en disent long c'est magnifique ça
c'est très particulier parce que ce
c'est c'est c'est un livre de chronique
donc il y a tout ce que j'ai fait de
mieux enfin depuis 5 ans c'est un best
of comme on dit en français
donc tous les matins
c'est je fais ce que je pense que les
les momes devraient faire c'estàdire je
comme si je tenais un journal hein je
dis tout ce qui me passe par la tête et
ça peut être des photos de moi ou des
photos de quelqu'un d'autre d'ailleurs
ça m'est égal mais ça c'est les photos
qui provoquent un souvenir parce que moi
j'ai aucune mémoire tout le monde me dit
tu as une mémoire fol du tout s'il y a
pas de photo moi j'ai tout oublié hein
donc c'est c'est c'est c'est très
intéressant parce que si j'avais fait ça
si j'avais fait ce que le le ministre de
l'éducation devrait faire aujourd'hui
c'estàdire obliger les mumes à tenir un
journal he le soir une page ce qu'ils
ont pensé ce qu'ils ont vu ça changerait
tout ça serait extraordinaire
c'estme mais jean-mar c'est quand même
un exercice de relativisme que vous
faites parce que les Stones les Beatles
le les voyages Los Angeles alors il y a
un moment qui qui je fais un peu le
parallèle cette fois-ci avec donc dan à
un moment voulait aller à la SB il veut
aller à la sbonne pour rencontrer con
Bendit c'est vraiment le seul gauchiste
qu'il a envie d'aller voir et pour
prendre des photos il arrive quand
Bendit n'est pas là que fait-il il prend
la Ferrari qu'il avait garé à 400 m de
la Sorbonne et il va rejoindre Brigitte
bardau et une amie avec Gérard BR
scénariste de polanssk à Rome et donc le
le 68 de Jean-Marie Perier c'est c'est
le rêve à Rome ah c'est un rêve absolu
ouais parce qu'on arrive à cet hôtel qui
s'appelait l'hôtel des des touristes non
l'hôtel je sais plus comment plus aucune
importance non mais c'était l'hôtel des
Français à Rome bon comme par hasard
l'hôtel de la ville de la ville comme
par hasard pendant maises 68 l'hôtel
était absolument bourré de mecs qui
avait décidé tout à coup de partir en
vacances tu vois il y avait pas de place
et donc avec Gérard brache il me dit
mais alors où est-ce qu'on va dormir
écoute j'en sais rien mais je sais que
brichteton est pas très loin brichteton
oui oh ben je la connais depuis toujours
hein elle est elle a une maison qu'elle
loue elle attend un film je l'appelle
elle dit oh oui venez venez elle était
dans une somptueuse maison et et elle
nous a fait des des des dîners pied nuus
sur le carreau pendant 8 jours pendant
que Dan et moi balancions des pavés oui
c'est ça c'était pas exactement la même
histoire en fait non c'est c'est c'est
le
négatif
Jean-Marie les textes sont nombreux les
photos sont extraordinaires pour celles
qui sont les vôtres et pour celles qui
ne sont pas les vôtres alors on va
prendre quelques exemple simple d'accord
la chose que vous racontez aujourd'hui
qui nous ramène au monde contemporain
c'est que aujourd'hui
interview d'ne Franck Guillaume Durand
Marion quetiller et cetera c'est
insupportable parce qu'il y a des
attachés de presse des assistants des
coloristes des gens qui et cetera et
cetera et cetera il Internet et la peur
ils sont tous là en train de vous
conseiller et là il vous raconte une
histoire avec les Beatles qui est
magnifique vous arrivez tous les
photographes veulent les Beatles on est
au début des années 60 et vous vous avez
l'idée vouscez vous vous mettez sur un
fond noir les gars vous allumez une
cigarette
oui c'està-d qu'en fait comme j'avais je
venais de les rencontrer donc une peti
moi je parlais très très mal l'anglais
en plus hein donc je voulais qu'ils se
souviennent de moi parce que j'aimais
beaucoup leur musique même si je les
connaissais pas je les avaent connu chez
Brian Stein leur leur manager on a fait
deux trois photos avec la porte rouge je
la bon et puis ensuite je me suis dit
faut que je trouve un moyen donc j'ai
pris un studio je les ai aligné je leur
ai donné à chacun un un briquet une
cigarette je dis à l'assistante éteint
s'il te plaît et dans le noir j'ai dis
monessieur allumez vos cigarettes mais
le problème c'est que à l'époque les
photos les voyait 3 jours plus tard donc
je savais pas du toutelque chose donc la
trouille donc la trouille ah bah oui
terrible je dis si j'ai raté mon coup là
c'est fini les je les perdu et coup de
bol ça avait marché donc euh il y a des
choses aussi qui concernent les Stones
parce que vous parlez de ah ou beaucoup
alors évidemment Jager arrivant et
s'installant tranquillement dans une
espèce de gigantesque glace en carton ça
lui pose aucun problème pas d'attacher
de presse pas de
conseil charmant avec vous participant à
des tournées vous y allez et alors il y
a l'histoire de Cock socker blues qui
est ce film de Robert Frank qui est un
film maudit dans
l'histoire du rock and roll parce que
visiblement ça ça a ressemblé à une
gigantesque fête j'étais dans cette
tournée moi je me souviens très bien
vous savez que vous allez nous faire des
révélations parce que les gens tout le
monde cherche à savoir ce qu'il y a dans
ce film bah c'est mais si on peut le
voir parfois sur internet en fait c'est
mi qu'il a interdit après je crois parce
qu'il avait raison parce que c'était
absolument n'importe quoi encore que
c'était la tournée de 72 et c'est la
première qui était vraiment organisée
parce qu'avant c'est Altamonte et le
reste hein cétait le bordel mais dans
évidemment faut se mettre à la place de
ces types ils ont un Boeing à
l'intérieur peu faire absolument ce
qu'ils veulent pourquoi dites-vous que
la scène des amandes lou mal avec Jeanne
Morau est la plus belle scène qui puisse
évoquer non seulement le cinéma et Dieu
sait que votre père François Perrier a
été un très grand acteur avec Melville
avec des dizaines d'autres m en scène
mais pourquoi cette scène pour vous et
quelque chose comme le sommet du sommet
du sommet dans les amants il y a la
première
évocation euh de l'amour de de de en
fait il y a première éocation de de la
jouissance féminine avec juste un plan
sur une main qui qui accroche le le drap
mais PvE savoir c'était pour moi qui
était vierge comme le canal sous la
Manche c'était un un truc terrible quoi
j'ai j'ai j'ai j'ai été fasciné ça m'a
beaucoup appris d'ailleurs parce qu'on
se souvient ils sont l'un sur l'autre
dans le lit et le type descend et
disparaît de l'écran bon donc on est
censé comprendre et là on voit la main
de la de Jeanne qui fait ça hop et qui
accroche h les draps bah ça c'est du
cinéma dites-moi comment se fait-il
Jean-Marie qu'étant un photographe à
succès bande de philiipi car vous le
dites on ne peut pas être un grand
photographe si on n'est pas avec un
grand éditeur de presse des grands
journaux et cetera pourquoi tout d'un
coup vous décidez d'arrêter puis de
passer au cinéma de faire la publicité
par et parce que c'est toujours pareil
ouver non mais c'estàd
que la vérité c'est qu'au départ moi
j'étais musicien c'était ça ma vie
c'était de de faire de la musique de
composer d'écrire bon sur une histoire
qu'on ne reviendra pas sur laquelle on
ne reviendra pas donc je j'apprends que
j'ai un un géniteur qui est musicien je
le vois sur scène il est pe dire vous
savez qui tout le oui mais moi je dis
jamais plus son nom mais non parce qu'il
s'est conduit tellement mal mais bref je
vois ce type là sur scène qui avait un
talent fou et au fond moi c'est tout ce
que je rêvais de faire bon donc j'ai
réalisé ce soir là que mon père François
pri m'avait adopté quand je suis né donc
je l'ai adopté à 16 ans c'està dire j'ai
fermé mon piano et
plus jamais je voulais ressembler à ce
type et là la chance est incroyable
c'est que mon père me voyant
complètement désarrois parce qu'on en
parlait pas tout ça est caché dans les
années 50 bon il me dit bah écoute tu
fous rien en classe c'est vrai j' déjà
je sais pas combien de fois redoublé il
me dit bah écoute je vais t'emmener à
Rome parce que je vais tourner un film
avec Fellini et je me retrouve tout à à
Rome dans ce dans cette tournage
incroyable et mon père était là très
inquiet pour moi et il disait à tout le
monde qu'est-ce que je vais faire de ce
grand con et il y a un journaliste très
gentil qui s'appelit beno grziani qui
lui a dit il y a dans les années 50
qu'on peut dire ça quand on ne sait pas
quoi faire de son fils on le met à Paris
Match pourquoi Paris Match parce qu'à
l'époque les photographes CIT les dieux
ou les Rizzo toute cette bande oui il se
tappent des princesses il roulent en
Ferrari il faisaient la guerre ils
avaient tout quoi et donc il a dit tu
veux être photographe moi il m'aurait
dit plombier j'étais d'accord toute
façon ma vie s'est arrêté en 56 donc à
partir de là j'ai fait tout ce qui me
passait par la tête j'ai changé de vie
tous les 10 ans de métier de de FME de
tout voilà parce que quand Françoise
Hardy avec qui j'avais vécu et donc est
mon ami pour toujours un jour elle m'a
dit j'ai rencontré quelqu'un donc moi je
vaux le rencontrer je je peux pas ne pas
aimer la personne qu'elle aime donc elle
me présente du Tron et là je tombe à
genou c'està dire que là vraiment j'ai
vu un type qui était tellement différent
des autres ouais tellement mais vous
racontez une scène absolument inouie
vous vous promenez avec du Tron assez
lent et vous tombez sur Brian Jones qui
est en lotus au bord d'une plage donc le
guit guitariste défin des Rolling Stone
le livre est formidable il est
formidable pour les photos il est
formidable pour les textes il est
formidable pour les souvenirs il est
formidable parce qu'il y a par exemple
une photo de Robert evons le grand
producteur du parrain et de chinatan où
évidemment Jean-Marie qui est un frisé
et qui n'a pas de mèche envie tous les
types de la terre qui ont des mèches et
qui peuvent séduire les filles à tout
point de vue mais nous allons revenir
car nous aurons une dernière partie où n
nous retrouverons ensemble avec
Jean-Marie pour parler de cet album
photo texte mais qui est d'abord un
album de textes de Jean-Marie Perrier
très réussi aux éditions kman ladyy je
le disais d il vous est arrivé une
histoire absolument vra le même monde
oui c'est sûr que c'est pas c'est pas le
même monde mais après tout c'est qui non
mais c'est la même époque c'est ça qui
est passion un peu après c'est un peuprs
c'est c'est un peu la même parce que
Street fighting mind et Rolling Stone
c'est quand même pas une chanson qui est
complètement dégagée Bob Dylan c'est pas
non plus une musique qui est totalement
dégagée une partie du rocken roll
français tross cétait quand même des
enfin donc vous ne cachez
pas que vous êtes sympathisant gauchiste
mais un beauon jour chez vous débarque
les flics débarque les flics et et pas
n'importe quel flic une bande de flics
qui vous demande et qui vous pose des
questions et j'en cite une par exemple
qui évidemment à broule pourp
fait vous surprend rouillant vous a
proposé 6000 € par mois pour louer un
studio que vous aviez donc du côté du
quartier latin et vous répondez je
refuse et est-ce que vous saviez qu'ils
allaient débarquer chez vous et pourquoi
ah non pas du tout en fait rouillant
étant leader d'Action Directe oui mais à
l'époque il était pas recherché il je
l'ai vu deux fois hein il était pas
recherché il se cachait un peu parce
qu'il voulait pas que il lui arrive le
même sort qu'à Goldman donc il soit
assassiné mais bref c'était pas c'était
action directe avant les meurtres avant
voilà
avant tout ça quoi et et moi j'étais pas
sympathisant j'ai juste je les ai
rencontré parce que j'avais un de mes
amis euh qui avait les clés de mon
studio et un jour j'arrive il y a des
flics partout dans Paris je sais pas ce
qui se passe on est en mai 83 et
j'arrive chez moi et je les trouve là
ils écoutent des scanners ils savent pas
ce qui s'est passé euh je il soulève les
machines à écrire il y en a deux une
ancienne une moderne non ça je parle de
de je parle avant l'arrestation la
raison de l'arrestation donc en fait le
le j'arrive chez moi mais il y a les
gens d'action directe qui sont là et qui
écoutent les scaners qui savent pas ce
qui s'est passé que je vire et peu après
arrive une
personne paniqué qui me dit ils sont
venus chez moi bon il y avait eu une
fusillade avec deux ou trois de flics au
tapis un assassinat Aven truden Avenue
truden et puis peu de temps après moi je
vire la fille aussi et et les flics la
brigade criminal reçoit cette lettre
anonyme que vous avez lu tout à l'heure
et donc il commence à enquêter sur moi
donc pendant des mois et des mois ils
enquêtent c'est en fait ils refont ma
jeunesse je suis sur écoute je suis filé
et puis un beau matin il débarqu chez
moi h et je les attendais évidemment pas
je comprends pas exactement ce qui se
passe et puis et puis l'enfer commence
quoi c'est-à-dire que Al l'enfer ça
aboutira à 40 jours de prison ça
aboutira à un procès ça aboutira à à
Wikipédia où vous avez beau avoir écrit
43 Mo et est totalement innocent cette
histoire on continue à raconter ça sur
Wikipédia comme si vous étiez une des
âmes d'années ce qui n'est évidemment
pas le cas d'action directe le livre
raconte donc l'enquête du début raconte
ce qui s'est passé c'est le procès le
développement de ce que fut cette
période et alors là où il est aussi
inoui c'est qu'un beau jour alors là
c'est le c'est le Dan Franck notable la
la la la la la porte enfin plutôt la
sonnerie retentie chez vous et vous
voyez arriver un des flics qui est venu
vous interrogz au tout début de
l'affaire Ben c'està-dire que moi j'ai
écrit ce livre en permanence quand je
suis arrivé à la santé j'ai commencé à
écrire je n'ai fait que ça et j'y
reviens
depuis tout le temps oui plusieurs
versions dites-vous hein j'ai fait plein
de versions plein de pages je savais pas
comment l'écrire et à un moment donné je
me suis dit je vais essayer de enfin de
faire l'enquête policière donc j'ai
essayé de j'ai retrouvé des documents et
cetera ce que les flics avaient sur moi
les rapports d'enquête ils ont été dans
les inspections d'académie diverses dans
les lycées j'avais fréquent ils ont
cherché mes petites copines parce qu'il
pensaient que la fille qui avait
débarqué chez moi était l'une d'entre
elles enfin bref il savaiit beaucoup
beaucoup de choses euh et je me suis dit
je vais construire le livre comme ça et
donc j'ai cherché pendant des années et
des années le flic qui m'avait arrêté
que j'appelle le Bordelet dans le livre
et qui à un moment donné débarque chez
moi c'est que je on se parle il vient
chez moi et je l'interroge j'enregistre
il y a 2 heures d'entretien c'est moi
qui pour le coup l'interroge et là on a
un rapport absolument incroyable que je
raconte aussi parce que c'est là qui
vous raconte que vous avez été balancé
depuis le début il me dit que j'éétais
balancé il me dit en fait euh il savait
tout j'ai menti depuis le début parce
que je voulais pas cette pauvre fille
elle était é lguée j'ai essayais de la
protéger je la connaissais pas hein mais
bon et et un jour il vient chez moi et
c'est une symbolique parce que toutes
les leurs enquêtes étaient comme ça il
arrive chez moi on s'est vu deux trois
fois il cherche cette fille et puis il
arrive avec elle la photo et il me dit
est-ce que c'est elle et moi je dis non
c'est pas elle h et il téléphone
ok Desf non non il dit que c'est pas
elle et en fait quand je le revois 40
ans plus tard il me dit mais je lu dis
mais j'ai menti il me dit moi aussi
parce qu'on avait arrêté le matin on
savait très bien qui c'était et on
savait que vous saviez qui était et tout
est comme ça et les interrogatoire que
je raconte comme ça c'est c'est des
parties d'échec qui sont terriblement
compliqué parce que moi je suis
là-dedans je comprends rien je suis pas
un militant je suis pas un voyou je suis
pas un assassin donc je suis
complètement et donc c'est très
difficile de jouer avec les
interrogatoires de jouer on sait pas ce
qu'ils savent ils en savent beaucoup
c'est 6 mois d'enquête 6 mois de
filature 6 mois d'écoutes téléphonique
donc en fait on essaie de tenir on tient
pas on reg cette jolie phrase Jean-Marie
et Dan j'étais comme la souris coincée
dans un angle par quatre chasse à ces
enquêteurs du début qui qui
s'apprêtaient à à à à à me la serrer
mais il m'ont la serrer ouais mais mais
mais alors le le le l'extraordinaire
c'est que que on peut pas tout raconter
mais l'extraordinaire à la fin c'est
vous expliquer que ce qu'ils ont su sur
vous tout su il y a eu deux choses c'est
que un c'était pas une enquête
terroriste mais c'était une enquête de
la briillette criminelle donc à chaque
fois que vous mentiez vous disiez la
vérité il le savait avant vous donc vous
vous enfermez dans un
truc que vous ne maîtrisez pas et la
deuxième chose c'est quand on est quand
même dans la grande période Goldman
c'est la période où une partie de la
classe intellectuelle en France vous
comme beaucoup de gens ont de la pie
pour Goldman l'écrivain malgré son
attitude on le sait qui a don lieu
encore un film aujourd'hui bruguère qui
est le juge qui mène tout ça je ce qu'il
veut c'est couper le lien qui existe
entre les activistes révolutionnaires et
la classe intellectuelle et ils disent
on va se servir de Dan Franck c'est
qu'on va taper sur Franck parce que
Franck est un intellectuel connu
milieu de ce monde là et donc en lui
faisant les emmerdements ça va refroidir
les autres c'est ça l'idée non il y
avait ça il y avait aussi le fait que le
juge bruguer il incarcérait beaucoup et
souvent ouais moi depuis j'ai des
copains juges que je vois de temps en
temps et je le donc il connaissent
l'histoire et je leur dis est-ce que
vous m'auriez arrêté non mais c'est vous
qui déécrivez moi je l'ai pas inventé
quand vous dites ça non non bien sûr
bien sûr c'est absolument vrai voilà
regardez le seul moyen qu'av brugerre de
faire pour faire peur au milieu
intellectuel c'était de t'arrêter dis le
flic qui vient vous voirûr oui non mais
c'est sûr c'est il m'explique ça 40 ans
après mais j'avais un peu compris le
truc mais à part ça il y avait quand
même il avait une manie brugire il
arrêtait les gens quoi c'était ça
parlait de lui enfin il y avait un peu
tout ça et surtout le fait que j'ai
menti c'est-à-dire que je suis arrêté
une première fois je mens h c'estd je
cache ce que deux trois choses que je
savais je savais pas grandchose mais
deux trois choses et le et le flic qui
me relâche au bout de 48 he me dit si
vous avez menti on vous retrouvera et
moi je sais qu'il j'ai menti mais lui
aussi il le sait et il sait queà un
moment donné il m'aura quoi et et quand
il vient me rechercher euh 3 mois ou 6
mois plus tard il me dit bon bah joué et
mal joué ben j'ai dit oui puis après ben
après il m'a embarqué après j'ai après
j'ai passé 40 jours à la santé j'ai deux
questions dan attention s de on n'est
pas dans un commissariat de police c'est
le bonheur au bonheur des livres mais
pourquoi vous avez parce que le studio
de Dan a servi quand même de logistique
à ce qui était en train de devenir
action directe qui était quand même par
rapport à la fraction ramer rouge et et
et les Italiens un peu des Charlots mais
pourquoi vous leur avez loué leur studio
non non pourquoi vous leur avez loué
studio non non c'est là c'est l'arnaque
totale j'avais un ami qui était un ami
d'adolescence avec qui j'avais fait les
400 coups après mes 68 quand on était
gamin ouais eu qui me le demande et pour
lui je dis non je dis non parce que je
sais que il connais rouillant que moi
j'ai pas envie de et cetera c'est pas
mon truc il dis c'est pas pour moi c'est
pour mon frère pour mon cousin qui est
déserteur et cajunisse et moi je le
crois non mais c'est quand même
incroyable que des gamin d'enfance c'est
que non seulement vous avez C ces
histoires de manipulation qui arrivent
comme dans un L car plus tard mais vous
avez un copain d'enfance c'est
exactement comme si je sais pas
Jean-Marie apprenait que Johnny son
copain faisait partie du sdeck ou d'un
groupe d'extrême gauche quoi c'est votre
copain d'enfance avec qui vous jouz il
met son cousin là-dedans et je découvre
ça je le sais je comprends à un moment
au bout de 2 mois je comprends que c'est
pas clair donc je je je vire le cousin
et en fait j'ai j'ai appris par les
flics que mon studio était devenu une
base de repli une base la base
téléphonique d'action direct là ça et et
j'ai découvert au cours de l'enquête et
au cours des interrogatoires la la la
multitude de trahisons dont j'ai été
l'objet le le la pire étant l'inversion
des rôles c'est-à-dire c'est lui qui
trahit c'est pas moi qui trahit ouais et
et c'est vrai que tout ça enfin c'est
très compliqué cette histoire parce que
non seulement suis pas fier parce que
c'est pas génial d'avoir fait 40 jours
de prison mais surtout c'est c'est une
amitié trahie quoi moi je suis l'amitié
pour moi c'est c'est très essentiel quoi
et et donc tout ça a étit très
douloureux et c'est pour ça que j'ai mis
40 ans à écrire ce livre Chalandon a
écrit un peu la même chose sur chon sur
son informateur en Irlande très livre
qui considérait comme étant son
informateur pour aller du côté de l'IRA
et voir les informations et en fait il
s'est rendu compte que c'était un trava
avec les Anglais voilà il travaillait
avec les Anglais c'était un agent des
service secret britannique donc je vous
conseille ou je vous conseille de lire
l'arrestation de Danne fr allit vivre
toute une époque et donc mes nuits
blanches de de Jean-Marie perriier avec
les textes de Jean-Marie évidemment à
propos de tous ceux qui l'a croisé euh
il y a quand même un personnage alors
jeaais simplement donneré le le palmarès
de de de de Jean-Marie Perrier parmi
tous les gens que vous avez vu meilleur
acteur Nicholson dites-vous euh
personnage le plus mythique j'ai failli
mettre des revers fredaster dites-vous
et musicien hors catégorie ERC Clapton
absolument absolument pourquoi ce trio
ah mais j'en sais rien la seule chose
que je sais c'est que c'est grâce à à C
j'ai encore cette oui c'est parce qu'il
mettait une cravate lui ouais il mettait
pas de ceinture et puis c'était
l'élégance quoi sur
terre et vous et vous expliquez
Jean-Marie c'est c'est pour ça que je me
suis permis de mettre une veste
aujourd'hui ce qui n'est pas toujours
mon cas vous expliquez vous qui avez
connu toute cette génération qu'il n'y a
rien de plus insupportable que tous ceux
qui sont en fond les les hiérarches de
la critique rock qui sont déguisé alors
que vous vous avez toujours été à la
rencontre avec une cravate une veste et
cetera alors que ils sont déguisés en
Beatles pour aller voir les Beatles qui
ont en général pas vu d'ailleurs c'est
très très étrange de vouloir ressembler
à quelqu'un d'autre ça c'est une chose
qui m'a toujours fasciné et et c'est
vrai que ça devait être pour pour Dylan
c'était infernal parce que je me
souviens il était ouril de mec c'était
aussi bien des professeurs que des
journalistes que des étudiants et il
marquait tout ce qu'il disait donc si si
un jour à table il disait passez-moi le
sel les mecs marquaient passez-moi le
sel tu vois donc il était forcément
givré toute la journée pour pour
échapper à tout ça il y a une photo
formidable de François Perrier triste
parce qu'il a été quitté votre papa et
une photo extraordinaire de François
perriier car je tiens à lui rendre
hommage pour vousou en train de danser
comme un fou avec George SP euh c'est
très émouvant les autres livres que nous
vous recommandons alors vous avez
martial Hu qui est un un un jeune
éditorialiste qui a publié un livre
s'appelle les années 70 sont de retour
c'est publié aux éditions Faillard donc
c'est non pas une compilation mais c'est
un travail autour des années 70 voilà on
les a évoqué parmi les personnages qui
ont un peu marqué cette époque il y a
évidemment Joe dassassin et surtout
Jules dassassin et Mercury où là aussi
on retrouve ce mélange entre la chanson
les variétés et en même temps le cinéma
et l'engagement politique puisque ça a
été le cas évidemment en Grèce euh de de
Mina mercoury n'oublions pas qu'à
l'époque c'était aussi la Grèce des
colonels un personnage qui nous manque
beaucoup c'est évidemment d'bad
Jean-Louis à la fois les chansons qu'il
a écrit pour Julien clairec les films
dont il a écrit le scénario voilà c'est
au aux éditions de l'Observatoire c'est
signé par christop Tardieu et nous
allons terminer par celui qui est alors
je laisserai le dernier mot à Dan qui
est vraiment le le joueur numéro 1 de la
littérature française s dit George
Perrec je c'est librairie du 21e siècle
seuil quelque fois la littérature
peut-être au-dessus de tout euh c'est
écrivain bien sûr avec un un rapport à
la lecture qui est formidable parce que
c'est un joueur était oulipien ouais
c'est un joueur donc il à la fois du jeu
de la littérature et il a avait fait un
jour il il a il s'était assis au au café
de la mairie à place saintulpice ouais
et il décrivait tout ce qu'il voyait ça
s'appelait Tentative d'épuisement d'un
lieu parisien c'est un truc formidable
et un jour on a j'ai écrit deux livres
avec avec Anky Bilal et et on a eu
l'idée don de faire la même chose de
s'installer au même café et de regarder
les femmes passer ça s'appelle les siè
un siècle d'amour et on a on a on on n
pas fait du Perec parce que perc est
inimitable mais cette qualité
sociologique parce qu'il était
sociologue aussi sociologique de ce
génie de la littérature était quelque
chose d'extraordinaire je vous remercie
vraiment d'être venu tous les deux vos
deux livres sont passionnants merci et
les gens qui regardent au bonheur des
livres comme toutes les semaines vont se
les arracher en tout cas nous vous le
[Musique]
souhaitons
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]